[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie so surprise
surprise it seems like we actually found
out who the flash season 5 villain is
going to be there was a casting notice
that went out even though I didn't
expect to get any news about this for a
while so there's a new brand of the
flash spring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll remind
everybody about the schedule and what's
going on at Comic Con at the end of the
video too so the big news after the
finale is that the producers said that
they cut a scene out that let us know
with pretty good certainty who the
villain was going to be I mean if your
big comic book reader and it was
supposed to be a lightning-shaped dagger
now there's a casting description for a
character they're calling Desmond which
is probably a fake name which confirms a
lot of suspicions that people had the
last couple of weeks so the casting
notice just reads a man in his 40s who's
going to be a metahuman who sounds like
he's gonna be about the same age as
Harrison wells or maybe a little bit
younger after a mysterious interaction
with dark matter was given not only
immortality but also the gift to disable
other metahuman powers he blames metas
for everything that has gone wrong in
his life and because of that his mission
is to wipe central city free of them in
order to silence his own anguish when it
says he's gonna be a fractional series
regular think about how much they used
the devote version of the thinker during
season 4 like you saw him a little bit
during the first half of the season then
a little bit more towards the back then
he disappeared for a while and then he
came back for the last couple of
episodes so right off the bat this
character screams cicada from the comics
if you don't know who he is he was a
villain from the Wally West era he was a
cult leader and he wanted to steal the
flash of speed but he also had the
ability to steal people's life forces
using a lightning-shaped dagger so
that's why when we heard there was going
to be a scene during the finale cicada
was one of the biggest possibilities
this just hammers that home the
description that he's immortal he got
his powers through a mysterious Dark
Matter interaction so in the comics
cicada is a much older person but he has
a really weird relationship with his
wife he winds up killing her so he's a
murderer but then he's struck by
lightning in gains in mortality he has a
vision that makes him think that he's
destined to bring his wife back to life
using his life force
transferring powers and the powers of
the flash so he thinks that he's
destined to steal the powers of Wally
West to bring his wife back to life
now the casting description doesn't say
anything about having a wife but it
makes it sound like really bad things
have happened and he's done really bad
things and he blames it on metahumans
that's why he wants to take away their
powers not so much the comic book
version of the character but what
happens at the end of every season is
that the flash has like some big problem
he needs to solve and in solving it
there's a disaster like we have with the
dark matter satellites that usually has
something to do with the creation of the
villain for the next season
the sky split open breach
which was berry both of them he made a
time I know who you are I am the future
flash when I have control of all the
time it will be you who is abandoned and
forgotten
so then in seeing all these terrible
things that have been happening the past
couple of seasons DeVoe came up with a
bright idea that he could actually make
the world a better place by dumbing them
down with these dark matter satellites
those satellites almost reached a
hundred percent penetration of the earth
so you have to imagine that there may be
as some people affected by the dark
matter before they solve that problem
but they haven't confirmed that the
cicada character comes from present-day
I'm just assuming that he was created in
the season four finale then because he's
immortal he becomes a much bigger
villain in the future where Nora Allen
comes from so when she's talking about
the mistake that she caused it probably
has something to do with making this
villain problem worse so here's what we
get to Joe and Cecile's baby roping that
in the really easy way for them to
include her in this villain plot and
make her a little more relevant as a
character like you know why would you
have this baby if she wasn't gonna
figure into whatever your plot during
the next season was the thing about
cicadas cult in the comics is that a
couple of the Flash's former friends
were brainwashed and forced to join him
so magenta was one of those people she
was a former girlfriend of Wally West so
it'd be like if your ex-girlfriend that
you still cared about was a flash rogue
and she was brainwashed by this speed
cult leader that then wanted to take
your life force to bring back his dead
wife who he himself murdered so what
might end up happening is is because Joe
and Cecile's baby isn't supposed to be a
metahuman in the whole thing next season
is the villain blaming metahumans for
all of the world's problems and wanting
to get rid of them maybe their baby
winds up getting brainwashed to join
their forces so it becomes a family
versus family without completely
demonizing their babies so it's not like
their baby is gonna be the main villain
it sounds like it's gonna be this
Desmond character if you didn't see that
season 5 teaser video that I did I'll
add a link for that at the end of this
the producers said that Nora came 30
years into the past
so remember there's a lot of time-travel
going on here like she comes back to the
past to try and fix her problem but in
doing so makes it a little bit worse so
the really cool thing that I'm hoping
that they do is that they jump back and
forth to the future so that you see them
try to work on the problem and it just
gets worse and worse and worse until the
end of the season where they figure out
how to solve it so I'm expecting most of
the plot to take place in present day
just because that's where all their sets
are it's cheaper for them to do that
then everyone
in a while we'll get to flash-forward 30
years into the future to see where Nora
comes from pretty easy to assume that
when she first comes back it's pretty
post-apocalyptic that I think the idea
by the end of the season is is they're
able to neutralize the villain in
present-day so that he does not become
like a crazy problem down the road
remember immortal so he'd be in his 40s
just getting more powerful gaining more
followers as he moves forward into the
future this is all about the flash
family and it's all about Barry helping
whoever this Desmond villain is realized
that he is the cause of his own problems
like he's responsible for his own
actions the dark matter that struck you
like Barry was struck by lightning
doesn't make you a better or a worse
person you're the one that does that it
just gives you powers you're the one
that decides what to do with them once
you have them so easy takeaway from
season five already is is that just
because you have great powers and great
forces or acting against you doesn't
mean that they're responsible for all
your problems and think about it this
way too if that's a big thing for the
villain next season it also circles back
around for killer Frost's plot remember
the last couple of seasons she was
afraid of her power because she thought
that it made her evil the killer frost
made her evil it just Kaitlyn not
repressing all those memories from the
past when she has her powers activated
also the idea of guilt and blaming
metahumans for all your problems is a
killer frost think too because it sounds
like maybe she did something terrible to
hurt her father when she was a little
girl and repressed the memory so that
would be a way to sort of tie all these
storylines together so if you want to
read that story it actually starts in
flash vol 2 number 170 is this his blood
will run part 1 breaking the foundation
the funny thing about that storyline is
that was also written by Geoff Johns
this cicada
storyline but he wrote it before he
wrote his thinker arc from the comics so
it's almost like we're going backwards
in the comics for our season 5 storyline
so it'll be fun to see what comic book
Easter eggs do they do from that but I
wouldn't be surprised if a member of
Team flash gets brainwashed in the
future and that has something to do with
why Nora Allen doesn't like killer frost
and doesn't like Harrison wells they
haven't officially started shooting the
new season yet that won't start for a
couple more weeks but they usually start
shooting in June so they have a couple
weeks under their belt before they get
to comic-con
which is why they have footage to show
up for a trailer remember last season
the whole thing
is barri not being on set right away
like where is he when is he gonna come
back so they filmed most of his scenes
indoors so they didn't reveal that but I
wouldn't be surprised if this year they
actually put noir Allen in the trailer
because she's already here so presumably
season 5 will pick up right after the
events of what we just saw or within a
couple weeks of that sometimes it can be
up to six months we'll see how much time
has passed but I'm assuming that they'll
pick up relatively quickly after this
big bombshell like oh wow you're our
daughter what are we gonna do about that
now like I've been saying we'll get more
information about what's going on with
Titans and Young Justice episodes when
we get to comic-con and I'm also
expecting in Aquaman teaser we actually
got a first look at his armor so when we
get some actual footage and some
information about that I'll do a new
Aquaman video but he looks pretty badass
so let me know in the comments what do
you think about them doing cicada is the
main villain for next season and how do
you think they're gonna change it I mean
that next giveaway winner when I post
new DC there'll be new Marvel posting
this weekend and some new Rick and Morty
just leave all your requests in the
comments below
but click here for my flash season 5
teaser video and click here for my
finale video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight